واقعه غريبه في مصر وتحديدا في واحد سيوه
التابعه لمحافظه مرسى مطروح الموضوع
تكشف مع سمير الجزار عضو البرلمان التي
تقدمت بسؤال عاجل للحكومه بعد منعها من
دخول فندق في هذه المنطقه
قررت اداره الفندق
وبدون اقتراب منه او حتى دخول منطقه
مشاوره له وينطبق الامر ايضا على مواطني
سيوا نفسها فيما يسمح للاجانب بدخوله
في مداخله عبر ام بي سي مصر اوضحت النائبه
في البرلمان انها منعت من الدخول لعدم
حملها تصريح من اداره الفندق يسمح بمرورها
بحجه ان الفندق يسعى الى توفير الخصوصيه
لنزلائه من غير المصريين
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات